you were the world's first superhero I
gotta say it's an honor to meet you
officially
I sort of met you I mean I watched you
while you were sleeping
everybody had picked up on something
that they dug about Coulson
he's a major fanboy he grew up reading
Captain America comics he did watch him
while he was sleeping and he totally
wanted design and put on the suit and
even though it violates everything he
should be doing he has to try to get his
card signed and I so related to that
that's how I felt when I met different
people in the Marvel Universe it really
connected the dots for me it really was
an amazing part of Coulson in it I think
it really made him specific and made it
more moving when he was temporarily
extinguished just stay awake eyes on me
I think the thing I get asked a lot is
you know was this always the plan and it
really wasn't they're really you know
I'm not gonna say I wasn't pleading for
some alternate takes where I was just
wounded by Loki but they were not
forthcoming and they were like look you
know you've had a great run and I was
like you can't deny that I'm having this
amazing thing but it was definitely over
and I went on to do other stuff I was
doing a little indie films and then I
got a call saying you know maybe he's
not so dead
and the reason that happened is because
fans connected with him he's the guy
like them the kind of normal person
amongst all these super skilled
super-powered individuals and I don't
think anybody myself included I could
have predicted how much that was
necessary how much it was important to
have an avatar someone kind of making
jokes about it but really fanboying and
psyched to be there and that connection
was deep and they you know people
started posting hashtag Coulson lives on
like bridges in Europe and beaches in
Africa and it was not lost on the powers
that be at Disney and Marvel and Marvel
TV and suddenly there we were shooting a
pilot where Coulson was back from the
dead
I'm clearance level 6 I know that Agent
Coulson was killed in action before the
Battle of New York
welcome to level seven we don't want to
bring him back easily that it was it was
a you know the Avenger we wanted to
respect the reality of that death and
Josh's idea right out of the gate was oh
no he thinks he had a close call and he
had this the secret to keeping me
Avengers and that just unholy
compromises have been made to bring him
back and he's the living embodiment of a
kind of sci-fi version of PTSD and the
thing that I thought they did so
wonderfully was the only thing that gets
him through it is that suddenly this
team of new young agents and an old
partner who he brought back Ming
Nguyen's character melindam a that this
family that forms in in the first season
of shield and the kind of exposure of
Hydra is really what brings him back in
and makes him able to survive
understanding what he's doing here
[Music]
they're not down here it was a crazy
call we're doing Captain Marvel it's set
in the 90s um we'll get you a trainer
I'll work out hard trust me but I do not
think there was a trainer on earth who
can make me look like the 90s he's like
oh no no don't worry we'll take care of
the face thing we do that thing you
might have seen it on Kurt Russell and
guardians and I was like oh I'm gonna
get some of that I went to work on this
incredible story I'm a Captain Marvel
fan I'm a Carol Danvers that whole run
is really amazing to me just the
possibility we might get the Mohawk
helmets then you add Blockbuster Video
and great 90s gems it was really amazing
it also Bri I'd done a movie with Bree
when she was a kid I've been I've
watched her become this force this
incredible actress and I just thought I
felt the way I felt when I read that
Robert had been cast as Iron Man I
thought why did they nail that he's he's
new at shield but he doesn't know that
much he isn't sure what shield really
does there's so many secrets that he's
not privy to and he very quickly figures
out that of everyone I've seen here this
guy this Nick Fury guy he seems to have
the heart and the swagger and that's who
I want to learn from there's an origin
thing
the bond between Fury and Coulson for me
there's no one else that trusted this
how should I proceed
that's up to you director I mean Sam Jax
has been one of my favorite actors since
the first time I ever saw him on screen
I've seen him on stage I directed him in
a play in Los Angeles while he was doing
pulp fiction so when I got to show up
and do a couple of scenes with him in
Iron Man 2 it was a thrill he's somebody
I fanboy over and it's just a big day
for me anytime I get to show up in act
with him that remains to be seen I don't
think either of us have spent our last
life yet I know that Coulson has secrets
and everyone thinks they know them and
then boy there's one more and I will say
the same is very true for our friend
goose played so beautifully by Reggie
the cat not to show these boys how we do
it you ready
I further faster baby that's right once
you have a daughter you realize wow
there are limitations on the way we
think about what's possible for women
from my generation and just ongoing that
are not just wrong but you see them
impeding the dreams you might have for
your own child there's something very
special about the origin story here
in Captain Marvel that is something I'm
really excited to bring her to it she
hasn't gone to many premieres it's not
really how we roll but this one is
special and I'm really excited to be
there sitting next to her as she
experiences this story